hey Michael from Vsauce here today we're
gonna play some of the freshest top
class best games on the market this is
free free games with pills I know what
you're thinking how could he possibly
keep finding top quality games
I don't first game is poop first game is
there is poop in my soup a title for
connoisseurs okay so here's the game I
walk across and I poop from the ceiling
oh I hit the box I'm not sure how I fart
it seems like I [ __ ] from my face which
is quiet and disturbing my score was 17
is pooping my civil rights quit it plays
jacksepticeye to part three parts
markiplier diamond minecraft match a
thinknoodles guava juice two parts
annoying orange other games
Annoying Orange another one gaming the
key of hype record with just keeps going
doesn't it just keeps going I really
thought I was first this one
look at all these people I'm copying if
you're gonna make a poop game make it a
good poop game I can just go to the
[ __ ] bathroom to take a [ __ ] right
now if I wanted to and that'd be a way
more immersive experience than this [ __ ]
larly what is this bear simulator so
there's the poo to-do list
all right the hipster under my umbrella
alright so you get different points for
pooping on different people oh and yeah
okay so you can move back and forth
that's why I haven't okay now my poop is
bouncing I don't know there's a hipster
hilarious I had the time of my life and
I owe it all to poopy so better been
than bear simulator I'm getting really
good at [ __ ] on people this is
amazing I love this game this is so much
fun oh look right in the face on the
mother naughty naughty
alright so I play for about three
minutes and I've already done most of
them and how the [ __ ] do you make three
parts of this I don't understand all
right so this one's called shake your
money simulator 2016 oh yeh yeh this is
Ken damn you look good again you get
that money get that money while I buy oh
there is poop look there is poop guys
I'm in so the goal of the game is to
throw money at cinema toh skin and while
avoiding poop and demon goat game oh my
god has changed and changed to
markiplier who's sexy beast god damn I'm
clicking fast oh god it changed it
changed to red Garrett alright Bryce I
have a way better game than this alright
so put your face close to the screen
alright trust me it's gonna be awesome
that's it keep dancing you dirty hoe did
I tell you to stop
next game here we go cold email nice use
of Comic Sans I enjoy it it's the week
before the India studious game launches
we need to contact the press because the
devs have to do their own marketing kind
of so what the game comes out they got a
spammer bunch of [ __ ] it's called the
email the press take time to send out
all the press key max what the [ __ ] is
this is that my dog oh it's my hand
there we go we're done that's pretty
good
these emails yeah hey we made seven
grand oh yeah another pooping simulator
and the stripper simulated another best
simulator another demon this was three
free games apiece if you enjoyed please
leave a like I really appreciate it if
there's any other games you wanted me to
check out leave a comment and as always
thank you both so much for watching
instead of putting your face to the
screen put your butt on the screen it's
gonna be it's gonna be awesome it's not
gonna be a prank or anything it's gonna
be great do it do it right now all right
here we go
there's pink oh there goes pinkie what
the [ __ ] was that
what does [ __ ] is that [ __ ]